All right. Hello. Hello everybody and
welcome to pharmacist Ben bites. No, I
am not coach AJ but I am here with the
amazing pharmacist Ben. Hello pharmacist
Ben and welcome.
>> Hello Becca. How are you today? Tonight
I should say.
>> I'm doing great.
>> Good.
>> All right.
>> So you know you you sent over an an
article. Yes, I did do that.
>> Really hits on a lot of things that I
don't think people realize.
>> Yes. Why do you think I Why do you think
I sent that article? Like what do you
think I noticed that made me want to
send that to AJ?
>> Well, okay. So, there's there's things
that people think are unrelated.
>> Exactly.
>> Oh, it's one system.
>> Exactly. That's so important. And it's
important on on several levels. The most
fundamental level that that this is
important on is the level of our
collective group beliefs.
Like the average person, even not the
average person, even the smart even a
smart smarter than average person, when
they have a bone problem, they're going
to go to the bone doctor. When they have
a heart problem, they're going to go to
the heart doctor. When they have a skin
problem, they're going to skin doctor,
etc., etc. This idea of different parts
of the body being um being treated with
different protocols by different
professionals is ancient. It's old. It's
from a time gone by. It's not relevant
anymore. But because, you know, it's
generational. We learn from our mother,
they learn from their mother, they learn
from their mother, you know, parents,
mothers and fathers, and it goes
generational. Nobody's breaking it. So,
here comes Ben who's and and not just
me, but other healthcare professionals
also. They're saying the emperor has no
clothes. He's naked. The medical model
is naked. It doesn't work because it
tries to isolate all these parts. So,
when I read this article, it was just a
it was a classic example of what we've
been talking about, but now there's
studies, which I hate these studies that
show that it's accurate. So, in this
particular study, they found that heart
disease is related to fibroids. But what
card what what person with heart disease
is going to go to a OB/GYN for their
heart disease or even better is just
going to try to treat it functionally.
Most people go to cardiologist for the
heart disease. They're not going to even
think the average person and by the
average person I mean of the 350 million
Americans or so 349.9 million of them
when they have a heart problem are going
to go to the heart doctor. It's just the
way we think. And until we break the
break the trance, wake up from the
trance, we're going to be going to the
doctor for these these kinds of
isolated treatments,
isolated protocols,
isolated professionals and specialists,
and nobody's going to get better because
it's all connected. And by the way,
based on the triangle of disease model,
the uterine fibroids themselves can be
backtracked to another part of the body,
which is of course where the two main
points,
>> the digestive system
>> and you wrote a book on the next point.
You wrote a book on it.
>> Well, the metabolic syndrome.
>> Exactly. No, the metabolic system. The
metabolic system is just think about all
the chemistry specifically. It's how we
get energy, how we make energy. But
really, metabolism is just all the
chemical reactions with some exceptions.
Basically, it's all the chemistry in the
body is metabolism. So, you got the
first point, which is I like to think of
the first point as the place where
energy is produced in big chunks. And
the second point is where energy is
produced in quantum pieces. But it's all
about energy. You eat and presumably you
get energy whether it's you know quick
energy or sustained energy it's energy
that's where we get energy from is food
right nutrients macronutrients
micronutrients the second phase is how
that energy gets produced
intracellularly
actually in the mitochondria themselves
and when you think about it the body is
a circle I call it a closed system it's
a circle no openings and everything's
spinning around inside of it right
unfortunately there's two it's Not
exactly a closed system. You got two
opening. You got one opening and that's
the food opening and then you got an
opening inside the cells. So it should
be just kind of logical that the place
where interference to the chemistry
occurs is by what we're putting in our
mouth.
But
there's a psychological hurdle.
You know we eat don't eat for physical
we don't eat for physicality. We eat for
psychology occasionally. And and I know
I can speak for myself. I know probably
one or two% of the times that I eat, I
really needed to eat. I know how this
whole thing works. And I still find
myself eating 99% of the time or 98% of
the time psychologically.
Not because I absolutely needed to eat.
Luckily, I don't have yet. Who knows
what's around the corner. I don't have a
chronic disease, but 60% of Americans
have at least one chronic disease. 40%
have multiple chronic disease. Sit with
that for a second. How do you have a
culture where most of the people have a
chronic disease? How is that even
possible? How with a human body that's
designed to repair itself? How is it
possible under the um the realm, the
rulership, the control of brilliant
medical model, our genius doctors? How
could it possibly be? And I don't mean
the individuals. You got to really make
a distinction here. The individuals are
good people, okay? But I'd be
embarrassed to be a doctor. Like I'm
embarrassed to be a pharmacist. I'd be
embarrassed unless I was really doing,
you know, working biochemically. But if
I was just following the party line and
giving people what they, you know, the
the standards of care, you know, beta
blockers for your hypertension and uh,
you know, calcium channel blockers for
heart disease, etc., etc. I'd be
embarrassed. Look what you're doing to
the people. Look at our country. You've
got hundreds of thousands of people,
millions of people with cancer and heart
disease, multi-millions of people, tens,
maybe hundreds of millions of people
with diabetes and cancer and heart
disease. And you're and this is under
your control. This is your kingdom. It's
because it doesn't work. People, the
medical model doesn't work. It works for
broken legs and when you get hit by a
car. That's what it's for. Everything
else is lifestyle. So, back to fibroids.
The uh intestine contains a group of
bacteria that process estrogen.
These bacteria communicate with the
gallbladder. And the gallbladder also
bile that is processes estrogen. The
gallbladder and the liver and the
intestine operate with food. They
operate with sugar or they operate on
sugar. They operate on hormones. Those
three areas that nexus, the gallbladder,
the liver and the intestine. There's
other places obviously the stomach and
the pancreas there's other places too
but that triad is responsible for the
diabetes the female health problems and
obviously for the digestive problems. So
it's simple.
If you have fibroids or for that matter
if you have endometriosis or if you have
dysmenorhea or if you have fibromyalgia
or if you have infertility or if you
have PCOS or if you have a whole
spectrum of female health issues
including fibroids, you focus on
intestinal health and the microbiome.
You focus on the gallbladder and bile
and you focus on liver health. And I'll
tell you how you do that in a second,
but you have a question.
Well, I was just going to point out, but
then you said female that this is
pertaining more to women.
>> Yes. Because women's more
>> men have estrogen as well. They still
have
Absolutely. going in their mouths.
>> Absolutely. But women produce much more
estrogen than men. It's what makes them
women.
>> It's no accident
that most chronic degenerative diseases
affect women.
Autoimmune diseases affect women
primarily. Hypothyroidism affects women
primarily. Depression affects women
primarily. Um, female health issues
obviously affect women, you know. So,
women are the the main victims of the
chronic disease process. Now, that's
true. Men obviously suffer from too. But
in pharmacy school, we used to call
estrogen
the sow hormone.
Okay? that was the name of estrogen. And
so this craziness of pounding estrogen
with HRT in people is from a biomed
perspective is absurd. It's craziness.
Absolute craziness. Estrogen is so
complicated.
And there's not just estrogen. There's
dozens of different estrogens in the
body. They give you three if you're
lucky. Sometimes they just give you one.
And and then that's supposed to and they
do that based on your hormone tests.
Your hormones change every hour. They
change with what you eat. They change
with what you think. They change with
your environment. They change with your
uh with your metabolism. They're
changing all the time. You can't And HRT
is such a big business. So we as
individuals, we as consumers, we as
patients, we have to begin to separate
the medical model
from the profit model.
If if we don't separate the two, the
medical model will become the profit
model and we will become, as Dr. Wall
used to say, ATM machines and that's
where we're at. And so what do you do?
So that that's the problem. We all know
what the problem is. So what do you do?
First of all, you focus on intestinal
health. I'm all about simplification.
I want to take big complex ideas and
make them simple. The simplest way to
reduce the biochemical disturbances in
the body that lead to all chronic
degenerative diseases is to focus on the
intestine.
Period. The only problem with that is
it's going to require a little bit of
psychological a little bit of
psychological desire
because you're going to have to change
the way you eat and you're going to have
to eat a lot less. You know, I we talked
about this last time. Eating activates a
stress response. It activates an
inflammatory response. Just regular food
does this. So, we want to get eating
under control. We want to eat like a
lion. And I'm not saying this to beat
anybody up because like I said, I eat
crappy and I eat when I'm not supposed
to eat either. But if you have a
disease, if you have this is we're
talking about here is for people who are
suffering from fibroids or endometriosis
or dysmenoria or PCOS or whatever it is,
this represents your solution. There's
no solution in the doctor's office.
None. And I I I I wish I had an OBGYn
that I could talk to in front of
everybody and they so that I wouldn't
have to just talk behind their back.
There's nothing they can do, but there's
so much we can do. If you want to prove
it to yourself,
you have endometriosis or fibromyalgia
or some kind of menstrual issue or
ovarian issue or uterine issue or female
health issue, fast and watch what
happens when you fast. Now, obviously,
you can't fast forever. You know, you
got to eat eventually, but fast for a
couple days. Watch what happens. Do a
water fast. Watch what happens. Now, I
was talking about this complex of
bacteria that called the estrobolom.
E S T R O B O L O M E. The Estrobalone.
It's a complex of bacteria that live in
the intestine that are responsible for
processing and clearing out estrogen.
The reason
we used to call estrogen the SO hormone,
you know what I'm talking about, right?
is because estrogen is so complex
because it gets broken down into many
different derivatives and it's so
powerful. It's the most powerful of all
the steroid hormones. And so given its
complexity and its power, the body wants
to eliminate it quickly.
How does it eliminate it? By
detoxification.
The bacteria help detoxify it. The bile
help detoxify it. Bowel, it gets
eliminated out of the body. bowel
movements. It's processed in the liver.
That triad, the intestine, liver, and
the gallbladder, that's where it gets
detoxified and processed. But we know
100 plus million Americans have liver
disease.
Probably at least that that many people
or more have intestinal disease. Many
people have had their gallbladder taken
out. The gallbladder stores bile. The
bile, we always talk about bile for uh
for digestion, right? When you when you
eat a fatty when you eat food, it goes
into the stomach, goes into the
intestine, right? When it hits the
intestine, from the stomach, you get a a
blast of bile and that bile helps break
up the fats and that's part of the
digestive process. But then the bile
continues in the intestine
where it clears things out. It clears
out waste.
What's supposed to happen if you're
having a bowel movement that gets
eliminated out of your body. But if
you're not having appropriate bowel
movements, that bile can recirculate
and now it's got the the poisons, the
waste material still in it and it
recirculates and then it gets shot out
again the next time you eat food and
then it clears out more toxins, but
you're not having a bowel movement.
It recirculates again. Now it's gets
stickier and sludgier and it keeps doing
this until finally you end up with
gallstones or you end up with some kind
of sludgy bile, some kind of toxic bile.
So the fact that the bile is clearing
out estrogen, clearing out toxins,
helping you digest your food, it creates
a certain level of complexity, which is
why you got to keep the bile clean and
the best way to keep the bile clean is
to be careful about what you're eating.
To make matters even worse,
the bacteria in the estrobolome
can reactivate estrogen. Instead of
detoxifying it, they can reactivate it,
making it even more powerful. It's
already powerful, but they can make it
even more powerful. And then the
estrogen can recirculate in the body.
Now, I'm giving you all the the inside
baseball here, the scoop, but you don't
need to know that. I'm only giving you
the scoop because it's interesting and
it kind of validates what I'm going to
say here.
Change the way you eat, especially
around fats. Number one, that's the most
important is the fats because the fats
are the most difficult to process and
obviously bile plays a role with the
fat. So, be very careful with that. Make
sure you're using your ultimate EFAs.
The ultimate EFAs are almost like a
natural anti-inflammatory, natural
healing molecule. They almost act like
estrogen actually. So you have to make
make sure you're pounding the essential
fats and that you're absorbing the
essential fats as well as well as fatty
vitamins particularly is A and D
probably to a certain extent E as well
but especially A and D
and then all the things you could do to
support the microbiome
the bacteria probiotics are definitely
important but also prebiotics can help
too and that is the fiber. Now, if
you're dealing with SIBO, small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth, you got
to address that as well. And you'll know
you're dealing with SIBO is if if you
bloat when you eat mushy foods, the
FODMAPs foods, those are the mushy ones.
Pears, dried fruit, things that have a
little avoc.
I think avoc I'm not sure. I think
avocados are probably in there, too.
Anything that has a little mushy quality
to it. Pears are the classic example.
And then
there's that very problematic molecule
called histamine.
Now I don't know a lot of people talking
about histamine except we talk about it
all the time because it's extremely
important to understand that histamine
is an intestinal molecule that's
secreted out of intestinal cells called
mass cells. And if you have leaky gut
that histamine can end up going into the
bloodstream. And the real problematic
thing about histamine is there are foods
that are good foods. This is why I hate
that good food, bad food list because it
mis it's so misleading. People say, "Oh,
I'm only eating the good foods." You
know, I'm not eating any of the bad
foods. Well, guess what? miso,
kombucha,
uh sauerkraut,
tuna fish, smoked tuna, uh canned tuna,
not not fresh tuna or not, um sushi, but
canned tuna, smoked fish, u anything
that has vinegar, eggplant, spinach,
avocados, ripe bananas, ripe produce in
general. All of these are high histamine
foods. And then there are foods that
trigger histamine. Citrus fruits. You
ever hear people say they're allergic to
oranges?
>> You You're not. Nobody's allergic to
oranges. That doesn't happen. However,
oranges can trigger histamine. They
stimulate white blood cells to release
their histamine mass cells to release
histamine. Egg whites, um, milk,
shellfish. You have people say they have
shellfish allergies. No, it's a
histamine response.
um chocolate, nuts, wine, all of these
can be problematic when it comes to
histamine. So, you know, I the list can
be exhaustive, but it's important for
people to realize two things. Number
one, this does not happen in a vacuum.
It doesn't just you didn't just get
endometriosis or uterine fibroids or or
uh fibromyalgia or whatever it is. It
doesn't just happen. Secondly, we have
tremendous
tremendous control over it. tremendous.
>> Not the do, not by going to the OBGYn
though, by doing it ourselves.
And the way to prove it is to fast and
to stop eating. That's the way you prove
it. And I said before, it's obviously
you have to eat eventually, but just
fast and you'll notice you feel better.
Then when you eat, either pay attention
to eat or eat as usual and notice when
uh and notice what foods trigger a
response. That's why food diary is so
important. And we have a food diary at
criticalhealthnews.com.
So this is not difficult, but it's
impossible if you try to do it the
medical route. There's nothing they
could do. And the last thing, well, not
the last thing, but the next last thing,
don't let them take your organs. Do not
let them take your organs. They love to
take organs out. Insurance pays for it.
There's tens of not hundreds of
thousands of dollars in organ removal.
And then they'll give you hormones.
It's crazy. Do not do a hyerectomy
unless you want to suffer for the rest
of your life with with be on hormone
replacement therapy and have whacked out
female hormones the rest of your life.
It's crazy. Unless you have a tumor or
you have cancer, that's different. And
even cancer and a tumor, that's, you
know, that's the end result of all these
things we're talking about. But if you
have cancer, that's different. But just
to get rid of endometriosis, heavy beer
heavy periods or or fibroids or
whatever, no. That's not the solution.
And so we have tremend number one, it
doesn't happen in a vacuum. Number two,
we have tremendous power over the
process. In fact, I would it's makes
more sense to look at your fibroids
or your um endometriosis or whatever it
is PCOS or any of your female health
issues as a sign,
as a signal, not as a problem, but as a
a a poke. Hey, you're doing something
wrong here. Let's fix this. You know
what I'm saying? And that's kind of
reframes the the things we call symptoms
that we go to the doctor should be
reframed as messages, as language, as
the body speaking to us. And when the
body speak to us, speaks to us, the
appropriate response is not shut up,
body,
right? It's not I'm going to just cut
your tongue out body. You know, the
respon the appropriate response is
what's wrong. Don't you think we want to
look at our bodies like our babies? You
know, your baby's crying. Yeah, you cut
your baby's tongue out. It won't cry
anymore. But that's You don't do that.
You could poison your baby. It won't cry
anymore. Give it some chloro hydrate or
some benital sleeping pills and it won't
cry anymore. But that's what we're doing
to our bodies. I mean, that sounds
repulsive. You know, you turn, it sounds
gross, right? I can see in your face.
But that's what we're doing to our
bodies. That's what And nobody thinks
nobody thinks about that. We have we're
living in this crazy upside down world
and the proof of it is how miserable
everybody is despite the fact that we
have all of the all the the health care
tools and protocols and devices and
surgical procedures and medications and
knowhow uh that we could possibly want.
We know all the molecular systems. We
know all of the genetic systems. We know
all all the enzymes. We know all the
stuff about the the tiny little minutia
of the body. But we're still dying on
the vine. So for estrogen, any estrogen
issues, number one, intestinal health,
first point on the triangle of disease,
uh do a food diary, stay away from prom
foods, do your digestive support
supplements, focus on fats, uh EFAs and
fatty vitamins, make sure you're doing
your plant derived minerals, intestinal
health. Number two, metabolic health.
There's a very uh important relationship
between the blood sugar system and the
digestive system via the liver and the
gallbladder and the intestine as I said.
So it's a short jump from intestinal
problems to metabolic problems. And we
know 100 plus million Americans have
liver disease, non-alcoholic liver
disease. They have to call it
>> they have to call it non-alcoholic
because it's the same liver disease that
50 years ago you'd have to be drinking a
plane of vodka out of a paper bag every
every day to get to to get. And now
everybody gets it. So they call
non-alcoholic. They even changed the
name. Another got the new name of it.
Why do I have an echo? Are you echoing?
>> I have an echo here.
>> I'm not quite sure why you have an echo.
I don't hear it.
>> Okay. So um let me see if I can switch
here.
Um all right. So then intestinal health.
Then the blood sugar system. Get on the
healthy blood sugar pack. Chromium
venadium ketogenic diet. Low calorie. Um
uh nasin ultimate niacin. Uh magnesium.
Magnesium is probably the most important
female hormone, also the most important
blood sugar hormone. And magnesium
deficiency is very, very common. A case
could be made, I hate to say what the
most important is, but a case could be
made that magnesium is the most
important nutrient to supplement with.
Very important for intestinal health,
for bowel movements. Uh, and then third
of all, um, work on your estrogen
directly with progesterone.
Progesterone is estrogen's,
um, non-toxic balancing cousin.
Progesterone and estrogen work together.
Progesterone balances out estrogen.
Progesterone is like the exact opposite
of estrogen. While estrogen is the most
toxic of all the steroid hormones,
progesterone is among the least toxic
and it balances out estrogen. And by the
way, men benefit from progesterone, too.
I make a great progesterone serum
topically applied. If anybody's
interested, go to truthtreatments.com
and and get uh either contact me and
I'll get you Pro Harmony. great for all
estrogen uh estrogenic health issues.
Remember estrogen is responsible for a
lot of things. So for fibroids uh
problem periods, sensitive uh sensitive
breasts or fibroid breasts or or uh uh
fibromyalgia, inflammation with your
period, progesterone is amazing also for
hot flashes. And by the way, menopausal
symptoms are very similar to histamine
symptoms.
The hot flashes, that's a that's a
histamine symptom. The anxiety, that
could be a histamine symptom. The
sweats, that could be a histamine a
symptom. So, it's hard to distinguish
sometimes between estrogen and
histamine. Also, estrogen will make
histamine more difficult to uh will
reduce the the um breakdown of
histamine. Low estrogen will break down
will reduce the the uh the breakdown of
histamine. a molecule called DAO,
diamine oxidase, and changes in estrogen
will affect diamine oxidase and cause
histamine to be released or or cause
histamine to build up I should say.
It'll it'll eliminate the the processing
of histamine. So, anybody who has any of
these kinds of issues, DAO might be
something that you want to want to
consider and you can get that um that's
readily available on the internet.
Diamine oxidase, it's a histamine
metabolizing um enzyme. Also, vitamin C
can help you metabol can help um can
help break down uh can help detoxify
estrogen. Um there's a there's a few
things you could do. Melatonin might
help. Um essential fatty acids are
probably the best thing you can do.
So, there's a lot you could do it. The
this article was really interesting to
me because it linked heart disease to um
to uterine fibroids. So, what's the
relationship between heart disease?
Well, it turns out fibroids are not just
lumps in the uterus. They're a whole
body disease. If you have fibroids, you
probably have insulin resistance. You
probably have inflammation. You probably
have hypertension. You probably have
some kind of metabolic issues, metabolic
syndrome issues.
So, if you have um if you have uh
fibroids, it's likely that you have
other things that can cause heart
disease. And according to this article,
women who had um
uh women who had uh
who had a hysterctomy, they had a modest
increase in cardiovascular problems over
the following five years. But compared
with women who had no surgery,
if you had a hyctomy,
you had more heart attacks, more
strokes, more uh more hypertension, more
obesity. It wasn't a huge increase, but
it was measurable. It's all connected.
Women who had um a uh hysterctomy
also were uh showed a modest increase in
cardiovascular health issue. And this
was on this was a study this was study
looked at 60,000 women with fibroids.
I'm not a big believer in these kinds of
studies. Nonetheless, the fact is is if
you have fibroids, you have a metabolic
issue that's affecting your whole body.
It's not just a localized fiber in the
uterus. And that's how you want to look
at it. fats, intestinal health,
metabolic uh work on metabolic syndrome,
liver, blood sugar issues. Later on, if
you really want to go all out, you can
start working with your thyroid and you
can start working the adrenal health.
But for the most part, you're going to
you're going to notice a dramatic a
dramatic improvement in all estrogenic
inflammatory conditions. And that
includes, by the way, skin conditions uh
by by fasting and working on uh blood
sugar, dislycemia, we'll say metabolic
syndrome.
Okay.
>> Okay. So,
>> yeah, pharmacist then I have a question.
So, how connected are insulin resistance
and estrogen metabol metabolism to
fibroid growth?
>> Intimately connected. There's a major
relationship between estrogen and
insulin. First of all, estrogen makes
things grow. What is estrogen's main
role in the body?
>> To make things grow.
>> Number one that but what make what grow?
>> Let's see. Breasts. Babies. babies.
Estrogen is the baby making hormone.
Yes, it makes everything grow. That's
true. But it's a baby making hormone.
Now, by the way, I forgot to mention
xenoestrogens in the water and in
plastics and in fragrances and in
cosmetic ingredients like sunscreens and
preservatives. Do you know sunscreens
are estrogenic? Every time I talk about
sunscreens on TikTok, I get these
knucklehead dermatologists screaming at
me, "Oh, how can you tell people about
sunscreens going out in the sun, blah
blah blah." They're among the most
estrogenic chemicals in the whole
cosmetic uh of all cosmetic ingredients.
Parabens and preservatives likewise. So
estrogen is everywhere. And that's
because estrogen is not really
>> chemical. It's a family. the structure
>> and it's found everywhere
>> throughout nature and throughout the
industrial throughout the synthetic
industrial chem the um the list of
synthetic pharm synthetic molecules
especially something called phalates
there's estrogens everywhere that's
another reason why you want to be doing
progesterone to help protect yourself
from the xenoestrogens
um and then so I don't want to I didn't
want to complicate things Basically, if
you have any estrogenic issue, focus on
fats, intestine, blood sugar, and liver
health and and the gallbladder and bile.
>> Since you brought up sunscreen.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. Let You're going to get
make me talk about sunscreens. Let me
just talk to you really quickly about
estrogen. Insulin. Insulin
>> is not just a blood sugar hormone.
>> It's a growth hormone.
It's a growth promoting hormone.
Estrogen is also a growth promoting
hormone. So between insulin and
estrogen, you got two major stimulators
of inflammation, two major stimulators
of cell growth, two major in um two
major stimulators of stress, oxidative
stress. Um both of them will promote
blood vessel formation
and fibroids thrive in this kind of
environment.
High insulin can also increase estro
estrogen activity. So insulin potentizes
estrogen. When insulin goes up, more
free estrogen is going to circulate and
estrogen activity will circulate. That
means you can have normal estrogen
levels on a blood test, but you can
still have excessive estrogen effects
because the hormone that you have is
more active. Do you follow? Did you
follow that? You want me to say that
again?
>> I I follow. And does that have anything
to do with estrogen dominance in men?
>> Yes. Estrogen dominance in everybody.
Estrogen dominance in women and in men.
Estrogen dominance in women is what
we're talking about here. The estrogen
recirculates. It's not detoxified. You
get lots of estrogen in your body. If
you have elevated insulin, that makes it
even more it makes it even more potent.
Histamine will also potentize estrogen.
So, if you have estrogen problems, you
may have digestive problems. Estrogen is
very inflammatory. It can inflame the
the intestine. You get leaky gut. Look,
you could talk about this all day long.
The mechanisms, it's very fascinating. I
think they're very fascinating, but I
don't want people to get confused here
because I don't want people to tune out.
The solution is intestinal health, liver
health, gallbladder health. There's
nothing you could do about the uterus.
Let me say that again. There's nothing
you can do about the uterus. There's
nothing you can do about the uterus
directly. But by working on the
intestine and the estrobolum and bile
and the liver, you can work on the on
the female health on the female organs.
This is why they give you hysterctomies
or they or they ablate or they remove
the fibroids. They can't really do
anything metabolically to the uterus
because it's a secondary system. Just
like they can't do anything to the
heart. Do you guys get that? You can't
work on the secondary organs. You you
you can only work on the on the root.
You can't work on the fruit. The uterus
is the fruit. The heart's the fruit. You
can only work on the root. And that's
the intestine, gallbladder, liver, the
digestive system in general. Pancreas is
also involved and the stomach is also
involved of course. So, you know, it's
digestive system in general, but
especially the liver, intestine,
gallbladder.
And if anybody has an OB/GYN, I'd love
to I hope tell them to come on the
program so we can talk to them directly
so we can hear what they have to say.
>> That would be awesome.
>> That would be awesome. Um, we do have
some people here on with us and have
some questions. Yes, Kiana wants to
know.
>> Kiana. Kiana's a perfect example.
>> Kiana, put her on. Kiana's very
beautiful lady. We want to see Kiana's
face. Come on, Kiana.
>> Show up.
>> She doesn't have her camera on, so
>> Oh, Kiana,
>> can you turn your camera on, my dear?
>> Kiana,
>> no.
>> I want to see your pretty face. Come on,
Kiana.
>> No. I'm so sorry. I can't.
>> Come on. No.
Come on. You're so beautiful. I have to
look at I got to look at the big K.
Okay, that's all right. Go ahead.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. So, I
>> Which one? I forgot. You're the You're
the one of the twins, right?
>> Yes. One of the twins. I'm the one.
>> What's your mom's What's your mom's
name?
>> Anette. She's in here as well. She's in.
>> Hi, Antwanette. Hi, Antoanette. So,
Kiana, you're the gal that had the
histammy issue and and you and you were
eating avocados, wasn't that you?
>> Exactly. That's me. You have a great
memory, Ben.
>> Yeah, I remember you. I remember. So
what's going on? How you feeling by the
way?
>> Yeah. So not good. So I actually had a
surgery. Uh hysteros hysteroscopy.
>> Hyerecto. Did you have a hysterctomy?
>> No. No. No. No. Hyster.
>> Hysteroscopy.
>> Hysteroscopy. Yeah.
>> That's when they just looked. They
didn't take anything out.
>> No, they did. They went in through the
um
>> What' they take out?
>> My lady parts and took
>> They went in through your lady parts.
Two fibroids.
>> They took out the fibroids. Okay. So,
you had the fibroids. Now, the fibroids,
did you understand everything we just
talked about?
>> Yes. Exactly.
>> Okay. So, here's here's the problem.
Here's the problem. They took out the
fibroids. That's good. Because the
fibroids themselves will throw off your
hormones, but they took out the
fibroids, but they haven't changed the
problem. Those are going to come back.
The fibroids don't just disappear. They
come back
>> unless you change the chemistry that led
to the fibroids.
>> You follow me?
>> I'm following you.
>> Are you still a vegan? Are you still a
vegan? Are you still a vegan? No, I'm
not. No, I'm not eat shellfish.
>> Okay. Okay. What's the pro What's the
protocol you say that you're on?
>> Oh, so AJ has me on uh uh uh RTQ and all
of the supplements that you mentioned
earlier. Um
>> foods. What are you doing for foods?
What are you doing for foods?
>> Foods.
>> For foods, I'm taking in more protein,
more fiber.
>> What specific foods? Like did you
eliminate any foods? Did you add certain
foods? What did you do for foods? I
remember you eating a lot of histamine
foods. Did you study histamine for Did
you study histamine?
>> I did. So I know I'm no longer eat
because I went I started eating eggs for
a short bit. I'm no longer eating eggs
because it can cause clearups. Obviously
the avocados like we discussed before.
>> I cut those out and I'm increasing my
fats such as like olives.
>> Okay. And are you noticing that you feel
better? Are
>> are you noticing that you feel better or
feel different?
>> No, I'm still extremely bloated. It's
still very difficult for me to have BMs.
>> Okay. The bloating is perfect. The
bloating is absolutely perfect. It's the
best thing. You know why?
>> Why?
>> Because the bloating is going to give
you real time information because you're
only going to bloat a few hours after
you eat a certain food.
>> Okay?
>> So, in other words, you eat a food, it
goes into your stomach, then it drops
into your intestine.
>> When it drops into your intestine, it's
going to feed bacteria in the intestine.
That's going to cause bloating. The
bloating is a response to the bacteria
eating the food you're eating or not
eating it but processing it.
>> You follow me?
>> So that's your best friend is the
bloating. That will tell you exactly
what you're eating. That's a problem.
>> Okay.
>> Well, it's everything, man. I drink
water and I bloat. It's everything.
>> Then that Okay. If that's everything,
then you got some serious digestive
problems. Absolutely. So, what you want
to start doing is you want to look into
and you're a smart lady and that's
that's going to work in your favor.
Okay. So, you want to look into
something called SIBO.
S IBO.
>> Oh, I've heard of this. Yeah, I can take
that.
>> Okay. Yes. And you can have it you can
have a test done, but you probably don't
need it because it sounds like that's
what you're dealing with. So, SIBO
is uh the bacteria that cause SIBO,
small intestinal bacterial overgrowth.
That means bacteria are only supposed to
live in the large intestine. Not a
little bit in the small intestine, but
for the most part in the large
intestine. Mhm.
>> Why do you suppose you want bacteria,
most of your bacteria in the large
intestine, not the small intestine?
>> Use your just logic. Think about it and
use logic.
>> I don't know.
>> Okay. So, so the large intestine doesn't
have food in it.
>> The small intestine has food in it.
>> Okay.
>> So, if you have food plus you have
bacteria,
those bacteria are going to go to town.
>> Okay.
>> You're going to have an all you can eat
buffet.
>> Okay. So, what you're probably dealing
with is this condition. There's a couple
things you could do. Uh, do you know
what I26 is from Jeevity?
>> I have it.
>> Are you using it?
>> I take it. I use it every night.
>> How much do you take?
>> Every uh a um a scoop, one scoop every
night.
>> Triple it. Do one scoop three time. Do
it triple it three times a day.
>> Okay. Okay. And then I'm not supposed to
say this because Rebecca's going to get
mad. I don't want to make Rebecca mad.
Look into essential oils for SIBO.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Because I don't want I don't want
Rebecca to get all mad at me. She got
mad the last time I said something about
But just look into it. Is that Can I say
that, Rebecca? Is that all right?
>> I won't get mad about essential oils.
It's just
>> I said them. I'm not going to say
anything, Kiana. You just look up
essential oils for SIBO and you do you
do your own research on that. Okay.
>> Okay. But I'm thinking to think the
beyond hospital.
>> That's all good. That's all good. But we
got to work on your intestinal health
for two reasons. There two reasons here.
Number one, if you have an inflamed
intestine, toxicity is going to get into
the blood and that's where you run into
the fibroids. That's number one. Number
two, if you have an inflamed intestine,
you're not going to absorb your
nutrients. So, you're going to be
functionally starving, functionally
malnourished.
>> Yeah.
>> So, now you got toxicity plus
malnourishment. So your body is trying
to fight something, but it doesn't have
the nutrients. So you got to work on the
intestine, the core of everything. You
know, it's in the there's a reason. I
don't know. Did you ever play
basketball? I think you told me you play
basketball, right? Okay. You know how
they tell you to watch the belly? Like
don't worry about what the guy's doing
with his head or with his hands or his
legs. Watch the belly.
>> The belly doesn't lie.
>> The intestine doesn't lie. The center of
the body. That's what you want to focus
on for all issues. The center of the
body. They call the dantine center in
Chinese medicine. You want to focus on
the center of the body. That's the
intestine. It's where everything is. And
then the liver and the gallbladder are
associated.
>> Now, do you have your gallbladder? I
assume you have your gallbladder.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes.
>> Your your menstrual issue, menstrual
cycles must be all whacked out, too.
>> Oh my gosh.
>> I can only imagine. I can only imagine.
I can It's worse after the surgery. Is
it worse after the surgery?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Well, there you go. You know,
that's not the solution. The surgery is
not the solution. They never change the
met metabolism. So you'll know you're on
the right track when you don't bloat.
When are do you miss periods or are they
really heavy? Are they painful? What do
you
>> Yeah, I'm changing every hour.
>> Do you Oh, you're like super heavy.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Yeah. Because you're very very
inflamed and you probably have histamine
issues as well.
>> Yeah.
>> All of that is indicative of histamine
issues. I I'm wish I was there with you
because you're doing something wrong. I
don't know.
>> I don't know what you're doing. Why
don't you I don't know what you're doing
wrong either because I only talk to you
a few minutes, you know, every every
month or every couple months. So, why
don't you do this, Kiana? Why don't you
call me,
>> okay?
>> Get my number from AJ and just give me a
call and I'll work with you,
>> okay? Because you're a smart lady. This
should be not this should be something
that you you you deal corrected almost
immediately.
>> You should be able you should have a
relief almost immediately. So, what I
So, so get my number from AJ.
>> Okay. And then uh I want you to write
down every morsel of food that you eat
and don't worry about a diary yet.
You'll have to do a diary, too, but I
want to see the list of them,
>> okay?
>> Everything you eat for a week. Just
write everything you put in your mouth.
Just put just write it down and then and
then when you call me, give me a list
and we can go over because it's clearly
clearly you're not on the right track.
>> But it's definitely intestinal. That
bloating is a major major. It's a sign,
but it's a good thing because that's
giving you real-time information.
>> Okay, Kiana. So, so here's your action
steps. You're going to call AJ, get my
number.
>> You're going to write down every single
thing you eat
>> at for about like a week or so, and then
call me and we'll go over it and we'll
work with you.
>> Okay. In the meantime, is it okay to
take or to use wild yam cream topically?
>> It's not going to change. You're not
even going to notice it. It's not going
to hurt you, but you're not going to
notice it.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> You got way bigger fish. Okay.
>> Yes. Okay. Thank you so much.
>> You bet. Thank you. And we'll hear from
you soon, I hope. Thank you, Kiana.
>> Thank you, Antoine. Good to good to not
see you. I mean, not good to not see
you, but nice to hear you.
>> All right. Well, Far, Mrs. Finn, we have
lots of questions.
>> Um, and one of the first questions that
we have, where'd they go?
Or one of the questions is
>> is
>> I'm menopausal
>> and I'm having all the symptoms.
>> Please tell me what I
>> and I HTR
>> HRT.
So um yeah. So uh is ask this person if
they're if they're a wine and cheese and
chocolate person.
Ask them what they
>> wine and cheese and chocolate. Are you a
wine, cheese, chocolate person?
>> All right, Mrs. Ammeritina,
are you a chocolate, wine, and cheese
kind of gal?
I don't have a response yet.
>> Okay. So, so anyway, so I'll answer it
and then we'll wait for her to respond.
Uh, menopausal symptoms need to be
regarded mostly as surprise surprise
first point on the triangle of disease
history.
>> And she said no.
>> Okay, good. So, here's what you need to
do. Okay, number one, you want to fast
for a day or two. Okay, two is better
than one, but at least one. No food for
a day or two.
Watch what happens to your symptoms.
Almost guaranteed your symptoms will
subside.
I I'm almost guaranteeing that. Okay.
99%. Okay? Because as long as there's no
input, you think about what a night
sweat is or or anxiety or jitteriness,
all that's energy has to come from
somewhere. So, as long as there's no
energy being inputed into the body and
you're not activating that stress
response, everything should calm down.
So, fasting is your best friend first.
Okay, that's first. Now, there may be an
outside chance that it's not going to
help, but almost guaranteed it will.
Then, when you start eating again,
notice what foods trigger the issues.
And then you're going to eliminate those
foods. Simultaneous with all of this,
not the fast, but after you start eating
again, you want to be doing all the
digestive support, including I26,
nightly essence,
um, ultimate enzymes, fucoid Z. A fucoid
Z should be regarded as an intest as
intestinal support by the way for the
for the gut or for leaky gut. Also
collagen peptides. If you can do
gluccoel caps, anything to build the
intestinal lining. So you're going to
focus on intestinal health. Now if you
have any weight issues or blood pressure
issues, chances are you're also dealing
with metabolic syndrome. The odds are
pretty good you're going to be dealing
with metabolic syndrome if I had to
guess. But especially if you have weight
issues, if you're gaining weight around
the middle, or if um or if you have
hypertension, high blood pressure, or if
you have any other kinds of inflammatory
issues,
uh blood sugars, you're going to have to
control blood sugar. And blood sugar is
elevated by the most benign foods that
you wouldn't think would elevate your
blood sugar, just like toast can elevate
your blood sugar. So, you want to be
very careful about your blood sugar. I
would get a blood sugar meter and test
your blood sugar first thing in the
morning and then after meals. After
meals, it'll spike, but you don't want
it to spike too much. You want to know,
you want to know where it is after
meals, but mostly mostly first thing in
the morning. First thing in the morning,
you want to see where your blood sugar
is. If your blood sugar is high first
thing in the morning, chances are pretty
good you're dealing with some kind of
blood sugars. If you had to guess, I
would say there's blood sugar problems
anyway. So, I would treat yourself like
a diabetic as well. And that means
metabolic syndrome, things like the
sweeties, the healthy blood sugar pack.
Um, and also I want to ask this gal if
she has any other symptoms aside from
the menopausal symptoms. Do you have any
um u mental health issues or memory
issues or brain fog issues? Do you have
any uh cardiovascular health issues or
or blood pressure issues? Anything like
that? Other symptoms aside from female
aside from menopausal symptoms? Is she
answering?
Are you reading? I can't hear you if
you're talking.
>> Rebecca, I can't.
>> She was in the room. She says, um,
can you say everything? I need again.
No, we're not going to say everything,
but you can go back and listen to this
live again and again and again. She does
not have any mental health issues. She
is taking sweetie. She does have high
blood pressure.
>> Okay.
>> Um,
>> okay. So any cardiovascular any heart
heart health issues,
>> arrhythmias, atrial fibrillation.
>> Let me see what she answers.
>> Tachi cardia
>> and it is Anuanette.
>> It's Anwinette.
>> Oh, this is Anwinette. Anwinette.
>> I know. I think I know. I I remember. I
don't know an I remember
>> I know I remember seeing antinette. So
Antwanette almost guaranteed has ins is
dealing with insulin resistance on top
of everything else.
>> So first things first
>> nodule.
>> Okay. Oh that's it's all part of the
same syndrome. So the most important
thing and Kiana and everybody else
listening the most important thing is
when you take care of the root the fruit
will naturally take care of itself. So
we want to take care of the root. The
root is where the soil is and the soil
is the intestine.
It's no accident that they say, you
know, people soil themselves. You ever
hear that term soil themselves? The soil
is the intestine. Bacteria live there.
You know, it's soil. That's the root of
everything. And that's where you got to
focus on. That's why fasting is so
important because when you fast, all of
a sudden that input, that flow of energy
into the system stops and everything
settles down. Right? As long as the
water, think of a cup of water. As long
as your water is jiggling around like
this, there's going to be activity.
There's going to be action. But as soon
as you stop the water, it settles down.
You want to stop everything. That's why
fasting is so important. So fasting
stops the movement. All of this stuff
you're talking about, the hot flashes,
the night sweats, the anxiety, the hyper
thyroid, the thyroid nodules, all of
those are the result of hyperactivity.
Metabolically speaking, we want to calm
everything down.
Fasting is the quickest way to calm
everything down. If you want to throw in
something else, slow deep breathing can
also calm everything down. Calming the
body down is very important. Um and then
you know things like meditation and and
just being still. You know the Bible
says be still and know that I'm God.
Right? When you're still when everything
is still
the truth is revealed, good health is
revealed. All the positive stuff is
revealed when we're still. So, you want
to still the body and you still the body
metabolically. The fastest way to steal
the body metabolically is not putting
energy into it by fasting. And a water
fast is awesome. Yes, water fast is
great. Somebody's asking about a water
fast.
But what that is describing, everything
is describing falls under this under
under the umbrella of metabolic
syndrome. The thyroid, the hypertension,
the menopausal symptoms, that's all
metabolic syndrome which itself is
secondary to intestinal health.
And as AJ wants to remind us, you fix
the root. Don't fix the fruit. Fix the
root.
>> You can't fix the fruit.
>> No,
>> you can't fix the fruit.
>> You fix the root.
>> Okay.
>> So, go ahead. We do want to say hello to
everybody who is joining us. Thank you
so much. We've got lots of questions
coming in.
>> We only got time for a couple more here.
>> Okay, next question. Um,
I got to scroll up to the top.
Okay, so Notorious Steph wants to know
about the glucoronolactone.
>> Glucaronolactone. What do you want to
know about glucaronolactone? So it's a
the one of the new products that
Youngevity is offering which is a
hydration drink electrolyte drink called
refresh FX has this in it
>> uh which is known to for gut lining
health positive response to stressors
and brain health and seems to help out
for chronic IBS leaky gut and ulcers
maybe
>> so glucaron gluc glucaronol lactone
is how you say it. Glucaronolactone is
um a breakdown product, a derivative of
glucose. The the liver will break down
glucose to produce glucaronolactone,
which then gets converted into this
stuff called glucaronic acid. Glucaronic
acid is a very powerful detoxifier,
one of the most important detoxifiers in
the body,
especially for estrogen, by the way. So,
glucaronol lactone has protect
detoxification properties. It's also um
a very important part of the connective
tissue for cartilage and for ligaments.
Um it's a structural component of the
connective tissue. It's marketed in
energy drinks because it's supposed to
um help boost energy. I'm not there's
some conflicting literature on there,
but the thinking is is that um it's part
of a it's part of helping improve
resistance training. But whether or not
it works that way, I can't say for sure.
I it's possible. But more its more
important role is as a um is as a
precursor to glucaronic acid for
detoxification and as a component of
connective tissue. That's its most
important role. Um if you take too much,
it can cause some headaches or
dizziness. Uh there's no real, you know,
it's pretty much it's pretty non-toxic
unless you take unless you take too
much. uh but it's it's m its most
important role is for detoxification as
being part of the connective tissue
although
there are some there is some literature
that indicates it may help improve
performance but there's not really a lot
of a lot of evidence to show that
good anything else
>> yes well and I know we have it and my
partner is loving it
>> as as for energy
>> well for his workout drink
>> for his workout drink. And but he's not
just doing the glucaronol lactone, he's
doing other things, too, right?
>> No, it's the refresh FX. And then I make
him put mineral stick.
>> What's in the refresh? What's in the
What's in the refresh?
>> Um, I will pull that up as we go to the
next question if we don't mind.
>> Yeah.
>> Um,
There's a long list here.
>> Yeah. So, how do you know it's the
glucaronolyone?
>> Well, that's what uh I don't know that
it is specifically that, but that is
what I was asking about.
>> I'm not it it may help.
>> Yeah, I don't think it's the
glucaronolactone that's doing it. What
other things are there B vitamins in
there or caffeine or anything like that?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Yeah, that's it's not the
glucaronolactone. Glucaronolactone will
support liver liver health. So you may
get better metabolism, but it's not
going to give you I don't I know it's an
energy drink. I've just never seen any
really compelling mechanism to describe
how it would help you with energy.
If anybody knows, I'm all ears.
>> Well, it does have vitamin A, D, E,
thamin, niacin, B6, B12.
>> The B vitamins, the B vitamins will give
you the energy. That's for sure. Is
there caffeine in there too?
>> The panathnic acid, zinc, chloride,
sodium, and then it's in the proprietary
blend that has the glucorono lacone.
>> Does it have Does it have Yeah, it has
green tea. That's caffeine. Does it have
grana or yerba mate or anything like
that?
>> No.
>> Okay. Yeah, probably the green tea.
>> It does have an
>> There's anositol. Green tea will give
you a little buzz.
I'd have to see the ingredients on
there, but I don't I don't know that if
the glucaronol lactone will give you the
energy, although I know it's an energy
drink. That's true.
>> Um, and for those that are really really
into making sure that they're
gluten-free, it is also gluten-free.
>> Okay.
>> So, farmers, it's been in the chat for
you. I've just put the ingredients if
you want to take a quick little lookie.
>> I do want to look at the ingredients.
Um,
oh, here it is. Okay. Uh, proprietary
blend green tea. Oh, fructose.
Um,
does is he say it gives him energy?
>> Energy.
>> Is that what he's he's noticing?
>> It just makes him feel good. He's got
good energy.
>> It could be a lot. There's no way to
know it is, but I would doubt it's the
glucaronolactone that's doing it.
Glucorono lactone. Glucaronolactone's
claim to fame is for detox, but it's
also um as I I said earlier, it's also a
component of connective tissue. So,
it'll help you there, too.
>> Okay, let's do a couple more.
>> All right. Well, so there's another
question in regards to our topic today.
>> Yeah. Yes. And what is the role that
magnesium, selenium, omega-3s, or
vitamin D play in women with fibroids?
>> They're all individual and they all play
very important roles. Vitamin D, there's
a reason why you keep hearing about
vitamin D. It's incredibly important.
It's not even a vitamin. It's a hormone
and it is phenomenally important and
many people are deficient in it. The
reason it's called a vitamin is because
you can be deficient in it.
Hormones your body makes. Vitamin D is a
hormone, but your body doesn't make it.
It has hormone effects, but your body
doesn't make it. So, you can be
deficient in this hormone. It's an
activator. It act it works with calcium.
It's actually calcium that's the
activator, but vitamin D is important
for calcium absorption. So, you can
think of vitamin D as an activator.
Without vitamin D, nothing works. And
because most people are deficient in
vitamin D, most people are operating
suboptimally or sub-ficiently, not as
efficiently as they could be. So vitamin
D is important for everything. There's
not a single cell in the body that is
not that does not benefit from vitamin
D. Magnesium plays a very important role
in female health issues. Um it's a
import and it's important for
detoxification as well. And then um it
helps balance out calcium. Calcium is
the activator.
Magnesium is a relaxer. So there's this
balance between magnesium and calcium.
That's very important. And because
people usually get enough calcium, but
they don't get enough magnesium.
Many people are operating hyperactively
either um hyper contractions or cramping
or things aren't relaxed. Magnesium
relaxes everything. So magnesium is very
important for women who are dealing with
anxiety issues, hyperact um uh
hyperothermia, hot flashes, night
sweats, all things that happen with
menopause. Magnesium has a calming
effect. Magnesium also helps helps you
fall asleep at night. A lot of women who
have hyper um uh who are dealing
menopausal issues can't sleep. Magnesium
helps you relax you. It's a calming
hormone or calming nutrient. Selenium
helps balance out estrogen. It's
involved in estrogen metabolism. So,
anybody who's dealing with any kind of
estrogen issues, selenium is beneficial.
What was the other one that you said?
The fourth one, there's a fourth one.
>> Um, the fourth one was
that's it. Magnesium, selenium,
omega-3s.
>> Oh, omega-3s likewise.
Anti-inflammatory, calming. They balance
out omega sixes. And omega sixes are a
lot more omega sixes in the body and in
nature than there are omega-3s. Omega-3s
are like a little almost like a
condiment. are sprinkled in the body,
but it's very difficult to get omega-3s,
particularly if you're eating processed
oils. So, omega-3s have a calming
effect. Magnesium has a calming effect.
Selenium helps balance out estrogen, and
vitamin D is important for absolutely
everything.
>> Okay, next question. I've got two more
questions. Does chronic nutrient
depletion change estrogen handling or
tissue growth patterns?
>> 100%.
100%. Estrogen requires nutrients to be
broken down. Vitamin C, magnesium,
copper, there's a lot of nut, selenium,
there's a lot of nutrients that are
important for the breakdown of estrogen.
The whole detoxification system has to
be operating at peak efficiency for you
to be clearing out estrogen. As
especially considering xenoestrogens and
how estrogen dominant people are because
they're sub subjecting themselves to
sunscreens and and pesticides and
plastics and phalates and new car
smells, fragrances, perfumes, you know,
all of these things add up. So many of
us are dealing with estrogen toxicity or
over or overestrogenized. That's what
estrogen dominance is. and nutrients
will absolutely help balance out and and
help detoxify estrogen. Probably the
most important is not a detoxifier, but
it's um a progesterone, which balances
out estrogen. And again, I have an
awesome progesterone serum. If you're
interested, con reach out to me at
truthtreatments.com or or um just send
me an email. Um also clearing estrogen
down through the bowels. If you're
constipated, you're not going to clear
out your estrogen. And what's worse is
it will recycle recirculate and become
more potent.
And it's sometimes it's not the estrogen
that's the problem. It's the they call
them catacol estrogens. Catacolle is
like is like you can think of catacle
like speed like amphetamine. Fetamine is
amphetamine because a catacle. So you
got estrogen which is already going to
hype you up. It's already a stimulant
and now you stuck a catle on it and you
got a catacle estrogen that like puts it
through the roof. and catacle estrogens
are really problematic. Those are
breakdown products of est or derivatives
of estrogen that build up when you're
not clearing out estrogen. So yes,
estrogen nutritional supplementation is
extremely important. All the B vitamins,
by the way, are very very important for
estrogen metabolism, particularly
vitamin B6, but all of them.
>> All right. And I wanted to bring up
because you brought up sunscreen again,
but since I've been on the 90 essential
nutrients pharmacist, Ben,
>> yeah,
>> I can go.
>> Yeah. Is that interesting?
>> I don't turn red within 5 10 minutes.
It's like I fell asleep in the sun
today.
And
>> is that interesting? And by the way,
histamine is a major player in skin
sensitivities.
for people who react to everything.
Histamine
>> for people who react to everything or or
um who are very sensitive to the sun.
Oftentimes, histamine is involved.
>> Histamine will make you break out when
you take a hot shower. You ever hear
people taking a hot shower and they'll
get rashes from the hot shower? That's
histamine. Or sometimes people will say
they're allergic to the sun. You ever
hear that? You're allergic to the sun.
People say they're allergic to
>> I used to be allergic to the sun. That's
a h that's classic histamine response.
You can't think about it. How could you
possibly be allergic to the sun? I mean,
it's the sun. What are you going to do?
Stay inside, never go out in the sun.
You can't be allergic to the sun. It's
not possible. But you can have a
histamine response and that can
sensitize the skin. Histamine is a major
major player. And nobody's really
talking about that. Although you're
going to start to hear more about it.
I'm starting to hear it a little bit.
There's something called MCAS, MCCAST.
Have you heard of MCCAST?
mass cell activation syndrome,
MCCAST.
So, you're gonna start to hear more and
more about that. It's already starting
to get out there a little bit.
>> Okay. Got one more for me for me.
>> Yes, I do.
Wyoming Annie wants to have you tell I26
works.
>> So, yes. So, we said earlier how you
have bacteria in the large intestine,
some in the small, but you don't want a
lot of bacteria in the small intestine,
right? If you have a lot of bacteria in
the small intestine, that's when you get
the bloating or the gas because the
bacteria eat the food. You're not
supposed to have bacteria eating the
food. Bacteria is supposed to be in the
large intestine, but bacteria in the
small intestine, they can eat the food
and you get gas and bloating and leaky
gut and inflammation and um problems
absorbing nutrients. It's a big mess.
So, killing those bacteria is an
important strategy.
I26
is made
from eggs
that have been laid
by chickens who were inoculated
with an antigen so that they would
produce antibodies. Those antibodies
come out and the antibodies are like
heat seeeking missiles that kill
specific bacteria. That's an think of an
antibbody as a as a as a um
a bullet that's specific for specific
bacteria. So the chickens make these
bullets after they've been injected with
antigens, with poisons, stimulants. The
stimulant stimulates the the bullet. The
bullet comes out in the egg. The egg is
dehydrated into a powder. And I26 is
that egg powder. They call it
hyperimmune egg powder. Hyperimmune
meaning it stimulates the immune system
because it's got these bullets, these
heat-seeking missiles, these antibodies
in the egg in the egg powder and they
specifically kill certain bacteria in
the intestine for people have SIBO.
>> Okay. I 26 hyper egg immune hyperimmune.
Yes.
>> Yes. So, you want to get with your
longevity distributor and ask them for
i26.
And if you don't have a distributor, you
can always go to dailywithdoc.com.
You have can access all of the products
that we talk about here except for
pharmacist Finn's special progesterone
cream. You got to talk to him about that
one.
>> It's a serum. Call 855-9493377
to get connected with a young uh
certified holistic health coach who is
also a longevity distributor. So,
pharmacist Ben,
thank you so much. Now, Kenya says, "I
need the sunscreen you mentioned. I was
told I'm allergic to the sun."
>> Who said they're allergic to the sun?
>> Kenya.
>> Kenya. Is that our Kenya's the sister or
is she the guy we talked to?
>> The sister,
>> not the sister. I got the whole family
going on here. Antoanette. Kenya. What
was the What was the other girl's name?
Kiana. Kiana.
>> Kiana.
>> Kiana and Kenya and Antwanette. Yes, my
dear. Kenya. That's a histamine
response. You're not allergic to the
sun. That's a histamine response. Um,
what you should be using is zinc oxide.
If you want to the best sunscreen you'll
ever use, some protection you'll ever
use. I don't like the word sunscreen,
but some protection you'll ever use is
my Xenolock. Go to truthtreatments.com
and get Xenolock.
I don't know if people know I formulate
skincare products. I have a very
extensive line of skincare products.
truthtreatments.com. I usually don't
talk about them, but I'm going to start
talking about them. Truth
treatments.com.
And they're not they're not like they're
not a joke skincare product. Most
skincare products are a joke. These are
not joke skincare products. These are
very very serious skincare products. All
formulated in my pharmacy.
And it only takes a tiny little bit.
>> Only takes a tiny bit. And you know
what? You should only need a tiny bit.
If you need more than a tiny bit of
product, that tells you you got a
watered down diluted BS product.
>> And that's all I'll say cuz I I step on
to talk about skincare. Don't want to
step on any toes. So, can uh can you
treat that as a histamine issue? And and
by the way, there's a condition called
psych um called dermographia
where you take your finger
and you can sign your name in your skin.
Have you ever seen this? You write you
sign your name in the skin. You uh take
your fingernail and you write your name
and and there'll be a little raised area
where you signed your name. You can
actually see your name in your skin.
That's a classic histamine response.
Okay. And then you might try
>> I don't have that histamine response.
>> It's a very good thing you don't and
some people like I say in the shower or
their bra strap. I've seen women with
their bra strap and they'll get this
rash right where they're put their bra
strap or the bra strap was. Um also go
online Kenya and get DAO
diamine oxidase capsules and see if that
helps you with the sun
and then of course all the digestive
stuff we talked about.
So yes, you can get the digestive stuff
by calling 855-9493377.
That is the day with doc. That is
the the the the parent of the pharmacist
Ben bites. So thank you AJ for giving me
this opportunity to fill in for you. I
know you're doing some great things
where you're at and thank you so much
for jumping in and uh doing some
comments and questions and helping us
make sure everything was right.
Pharmacis has been We've got a great
team. We are so thankful that you are
part of that team.
>> Thank you. I'm honored.
>> Thank you. Yes, we are looking for more.
Absolutely. We need more people. We need
distributors.
We need distributors
>> because there's how many million people
in the United States
is international.
>> 350 million people in the United States.
Yes. In international, too. That's
right.
>> All right. Thank you, AJ. Thank you,
Rebecca. Thank you, Ruth, Ellen. Thank
you everybody who's on the call. And
we'll see you on Friday.
>> All right. Sounds good. Farm is Fridays
on Daily with Doc, folks. That is 12 to
1:00 p.m. Pacific, 1:2 Mountain, 23
central, 3 to 4 Eastern. And you can
join us live in the Zoom or watch us
here on this channel by going to
zoom.dailywithdoc.com.
Bar Mrs. Ben, have a fantastic evening
and thank you so much for being here
with us as we once again empower more
individuals on what they can do
themselves to be healthier. And we're
fixing the root, not just fixing the
fruit like all the many different
specialists
are looking at.
So,
have a great one everybody. Again,
that's 855-9493377
if you do not already have a Young
distributor. And until next time, bye
for now.
Oh
yeah.